you ain't you haven't got i've been in
real situations and you don't it's
milliseconds you've got milliseconds
that's that technique you was doing
i can't lift it up lower it down i can't
do anything more so where does it come
from
let's do it simon so you can see
see this hand
see now we've got two techniques that
look exactly the same
i don't know what foot he's got forward
so
i could be like this but it would help
if i'm in hand me but i could be like
this
because i don't know what foot he's got
forward i have to choose what way i'm
going to go
so i'm going to
go this way or this way
this way this way how am i going to lift
my arms up
i can't lift them up so i'll leave them
where they are
i take it out i leave him where he is
i step out here we're back to almost now
category if you think about it and then
i push him down
so i've now got two techniques that i
don't have to worry about oh how many
techniques we've got to remember
because i'm starting to piece them
together slowly
if i
do this
and that
from usierdo
i can't bring it
i can't bring it up
but i can leave it there and i can move
my buttock to my hand my buttock to my
hand
okay and then you know the rest
okay
on a gas mask
don't